you know I've been thinking a lot lately
about how lucky we are to live in the
land of the free as opposed to an
autocratic country like Russia or China
you see in Putin's Russia the Press
isn't free instead it serves the
interests of the regime on whose behalf
it spreads lies and propaganda can you
imagine
even worse is communist China
in communist China citizens are under
constant surveillance the government
knows pretty much every single move they
make regardless of any nominal rights to
privacy in Russia and China citizens
don't have a practical right to free
speech even if they have such a right in
theory if they ever contradict the
prevailing Orthodoxy of the regime they
can be censored and kicked out of the
Public Square
in those kinds of countries agents of
the state even deny parents right to
raise their own children law enforcement
persecutes people for their traditional
religious beliefs
and most brazenly of all evil autocrats
like Xi Jinping and Vladimir Putin jail
their political opponents
thank goodness we don't live in a
country
like that
got a lot coming up to talk about uh
president Trump has just made
a really interesting statement about
Ukraine that is going to shake up not
only the race but is shaking up
Republican party Orthodoxy on foreign
matters a lot being shaken up these days
especially in the economy it's why you
got to check out Birch gold right now
text Knowles to 98 98 98 this month we
have seen the second largest bank
failure in the U.S things are extremely
turbulent right now and the stock market
hates turbulence you need to diversify
at least some of your assets into
precious metals gold is a tangible asset
with a reliable store of value because
it's not tied to any one economy or
currency it can be a safe haven in times
of Crisis Birch gold makes it easy to
roll over your IRA or 401K into an IRA
backed by physical gold and silver this
is the last week that if you buy gold
you can get a free safe to store it in
I'm qualifying purchases now through
March 31st Birch gold will ship a free
safe directly to your door text Knowles
Canada wlas to 98 98 98 to claim your
free info kit on gold and to claim
eligibility for your free safe if you're
interested in Gold this would be the
time to look into it with your
retirement at stake you want to be
confident in the financial services
companies that you work with including
who you choose for purchasing physical
precious metals text Knowles kwles to 98
98 98 and protect your savings with gold
today
thank goodness we don't live in a
country like oh look what does this card
say right here it says president Trump
might be arrested on Tuesday huh that's
weird this according to president Trump
though it comes after an NBC report that
prosecutors in New York are preparing to
indict
Trump what are they going to indict him
over
is it Russia collusion is it Ukraine
collusion is it is classified documents
that Biden apparently had multiples of
at his home that didn't really matter it
was only when Trump had it that was a
bad thing no no it's none of that
the libs in New York are looking to
indict Trump
over his hush money payment to Stormy
Daniels back in 2016.
they've gone through so many attempts to
try to get Trump they're now onto reruns
they're now going back to the originals
and so what's the what's the issue here
why is it a crime for Trump to pay
Stormy Daniels
well
he paid it through Michael Cohen who is
his former attorney
who sang like a songbird and now and
completely turned on Trump broke under
pressure and uh got a slightly more
lenient treatment apparently by the uh
liberals than he otherwise would have
would have gotten
he says that he made the payment on
Trump's behalf two Stormy Daniels to
keep her quiet about an alleged 2006
Affair that they had
then Cohen pleaded guilty to related
charges and served time in prison why is
it a crime because the payment was
listed as a legal expense
and the company cited a retainer
agreement with Cohen
but the this particular retainer
apparently did not exist even though
Cohen was Trump's lawyer for a long time
there was no legal retainer in this
particular incident and so
Trump may have committed a misdemeanor
of falsifying business records
the report said that Trump personally
signed several checks to Cohen while he
was serving as president
now a misdemeanor why are you going to
arrest the former president and the
current chief rival to the sitting
president over a misdemeanor well they
can elevate it to a felony if they can
prove that Trump's quote intent to
defraud included an intent to commit or
conceal a second crime and the libs are
arguing that the second crime is that
the 130 thousand dollar hush money
payment to Stormy Daniels was actually
an improper political contribution
because he was making the payment to
keep her quiet during the campaign so
it's as though it were an improper
donation to The Campaign which again is
bogus pretty much every campaign Finance
matter is bogus because money is
fungible so if you if you give x amount
of money to a candidate's Campaign
Committee that can land you in prison
but if you give 10 times that amount of
money to a Super PAC that's totally fine
if one group gives money it's okay if an
individual or a different group gives
money that can that can be a big problem
so it's all all basically bogus but the
reason this is especially bogus is that
Trump is the candidate and candidates
can give as much money to their
campaigns as they want so even if the
prosecutors in New York argue that this
was an improper donation to The Campaign
maybe it was done through a kind of
improper Channel maybe the paperwork was
a little bit off but it's still Donald
Trump donating to his own campaign it's
so patently absurd
it's so obvious that the Democrats here
just want to stop the people from having
a chance to re-elect Donald Trump
because they're afraid that if Trump can
appear on a ballot they're afraid that
if Trump can mount a real presidential
campaign that the people will vote for
him and so they're doing everything they
can they tried to disqualify him using
the 14th Amendment they tried to uh they
had multiple suits to try to keep him
off the ballots in different states
around the country they have tried to
impeach him multiple times they Trot now
they're trying to lock him into prison
from from which place he could still run
for president but who obviously would
hurt his campaign if he were stuck in a
jail cell instead of holding rallies
it's so obvious
that these guys fear Trump and want to
do everything they can to prevent the
people from having a choice that this is
the silver lining of this whole storm
cloud
the Silver Lining is
that I think we can finally dismiss once
and for all all the ridiculous piffle
that the Democrats tell us about
our sacred democracy
our Donald Trump and the Republicans are
a threat to our
sacred temples of democracy are
cherished norms
we don't act like this in America we're
better than this no you're not better
than this you're breaking all the Norms
you are undermining our allegedly sacred
democracy you're jailing your political
opponents like a two-bit dictator in a
Banana Republic which
some of us conservatives have observed
for a long time
so okay that's how they want to play
fine I do not want to hear it anymore
about our sacred democracy or any of
that other stuff
don't want to hear it one little bit
what should the Republicans do in
response I think
that a republican governor
or more precisely I guess a republican
Attorney General
should arrest a prominent criminal lib
there is no shortage of candidates of
prominent liberal politicos who have
committed crimes
look around the Clinton circles look
around the Biden circles look at Clinton
and Biden themselves
plenty of big criminal Libs out there
who have completely gotten off the hook
and there are plenty of Republican
Governors and Attorneys General out
there I think you would need a
republican Governor as well as an
attorney general because if the Attorney
General
indicts a big prominent
criminal lib
and and there's a Democrat Governor the
Democrat Governor will apply political
pressure
or eventually probably just pardon the
criminal lib so I think you need to have
a republican Governor there as well but
let's do it let's let's indict a big
criminal lib let's let's indict two of
them
that they are going after our guy let's
go after five of their guys
there's no risk here some people push
back against this suggestion they say
well we're better than them Michael
we're yeah sure I think we are better
than them I'm not suggesting we do
anything illegal or unjust
I'm not saying we go after an innocent
live I'm saying we should go after a
criminal live against him the law has
not been applied the argument against
doing that is that we want to preserve
our norms and we don't want to live in a
country where we throw the the
vanquished political opposition into
orange jumpsuits I agree I don't want to
live in that country but
the only reason for which we should be
concerned about that Norm is if the norm
continues to exist the libs are breaking
that Norm that's not our fault we have
nothing to say we're saying don't
violate the norm don't don't start
arresting the opposition leaders in our
country but if they're if they're going
to do that then we've got to play the
game otherwise we're just surrendering
to the people who are abusing our
political system the most so okay they
want to indict Trump fine I I want to
see every Republican governor and
attorney general with the political
Capital with the power to do so to
indict prominent criminal Libs and I
think you should indict multiple and you
should throw the book at them and you
should find every stupid little fake
misdemeanor charge and you should trump
it up as high as you possibly can okay
you the the the reason that you have to
do this the reason this would be good
for our political order is because it
would show
the libs that there are consequences to
their actions it would discourage
further predations on our political
order I remember the great the late
great historian Donald Kagan
professor of Mining College historian of
war and specifically of ancient Greece
in the Peloponnesian War
and when he would get down to these
margin calls why did Pericles do this
why did this Statesman do that he would
say
my inclination is to what motivated this
Statesman in this action
or in this in this strategy
comes from one place and it's the
Brooklyn schoolyard and because Donald
Kagan grew up in Brooklyn is kind of a
tough New York kid became a very
distinguished Professor he said the
Brooklyn schoolyard the rules hold the
same the rules of war the rules of
politics they're the exact same as when
you walk up to a bully
in the playground
okay and so if we do not push back if we
just roll over and allow the libs to
start arresting the leader of the
opposition in the United States
we say well we're preserving the Norms
you're not preserving any Norm you're
you're helping the Liberals to establish
a new Norm which is that the
conservatives never have a shot to win
and if conservatives ever stand up
against the regime in any significant
way they will be wearing an orange
jumpsuit the silver lining for Trump
here
is
they restored his YouTube account
that's I just imagine Trump having a
meeting with the regime from having a
meeting with the ruling class and they
say hey Donald
hey opposition party we've got good news
and bad news
and what's the good news well the good
news is
we're going to let you broadcast on
YouTube again so we're going to let you
back into the Public Square
you can post videos to YouTube oh great
what's the bad news you can do it from
prison there's trade-offs in life and
and the timing is so weird they announce
this just as the rumors start flying
that that they're going to arrest Trump
it seems coordinated
it seems and so much of our ruling class
seems coordinated the media coordinates
with the government big Tech coordinates
with the Deep State we know that they
have regular meetings with the FBI and
the FBI says don't post this story it's
going to be damaging to Joe Biden don't
allow people even to privately message
the story about Hunter Biden's laptop
okay sounds good and there's all this
coordination that goes on
and now the very same day hey we're
gonna let Trump back on YouTube isn't
that fair by the way we're going to
arrest him okay meanwhile what are the
Democrats doing
well we just got new information from a
house oversight committee
that another Biden
has been taking money from communist
China according to house oversight quote
over the course of several years members
of the Biden family and their their
companies received over 1.3 million
dollars in payments from accounts
related to their associate Rob Walker
most of this money came as a result of a
wire from a Chinese Energy company and
went not only to Hunter and James Biden
James as Joe Biden's brother
but also to Hallie Biden Hallie Biden
if I'm getting my Biden women straight
was
is Beau Biden's Widow
and then the paramour of Hunter Biden
after that as well as an unknown Biden
who is the unknown Biden one can only
speculate
the corruption
is barely hidden it's not even hidden
when Hunter Biden was on the take and he
was being paid 50 Grand a month or
thereabouts by a Ukrainian State Energy
company barisma
that was pretty Brazen corruption Hunter
Biden doesn't know anything about
Ukraine Hunter Biden doesn't know
anything about the energy industry
Hunter Biden wasn't providing any
services to barisma other than giving
access to the vice president of the
United States who's now the president of
the United States who was who was
Biden's I'm sorry who was Obama's Point
person on Ukraine I sometimes say obiden
because it seems to be the same cabal of
people
that was Brazen transparent corruption
now
we find out the bidens have been on the
take from communist China they haven't
even really been been masking it and
washing the money through different
people the wire came from a Chinese
Energy company so the wire came with
direct Fingerprints of the Chinese
Communist party on it
are any of the bidens looking at any
consequences for this no
no if if the bidens had used their own
money to pay some alleged hush payment
to a porn star then they'd have the book
thrown at them but if they're taking
corrupt money from communist China to
sell American influence overseas not
really disclose this money it's just
coming out now oh that's totally fun
barely hidden two tracks of Justice
and it's the squish conservatives who
are the ones saying well we can't
violate our Norms maybe we should just
let them arrest the leader of the
opposition just this week because we
don't like he's very mean and sends Mean
Tweets some back when he was allowed to
have a Twitter account he he and so
let's just let's just move on
can we just move on please
to preserve the Norms in our sacred
democracy yeah I don't think so
I don't think so I don't think we can do
that now
some people recognize that this is a
pivotal moment in American history this
has never happened before we have never
arrested the former president and more
importantly than him being a former
president the current chief rival the
current biggest threat to the sitting
president could be arrested some people
recognize this this might be a real
Turning Point in history including
people who are also running for
president including people like my
friend the fake ramaswamy who had this
to say
this morning we learned that it is
likely
that the New York Manhattan district
attorney
is likely to indict a former president
of the United States who is running for
office now I want to be very clear
I am in a presidential primary running
against that individual Donald Trump
but what I'm about to say has nothing to
do with Donald Trump
and everything to do with the Integrity
of an election
and the Integrity of a self-governing
democracy so I don't care whether you
root for Trump or whether you don't
if you root for the Integrity of our
constitutional republic then you need to
be on the side of being really clear we
cannot have politically empowered
prosecutors eliminating the opposition
of a ruling party using arrest power it
is a sad day in America
so if event goes on and he calls on the
other candidates in the race and the
other presumed candidates in the race
people like Ron DeSantis to
to condemn this
as these rumors are flying as these
Lakes come out as NBC is reporting yeah
Trump is looking like he'll be arrested
before it happens because once it
happens it's too late before it happens
the fake is saying these candidates need
to condemn this and make it clear we
will not go along with it even though
the other candidates in the Republican
primary would benefit
if Trump is arrested they would probably
benefit Trump would get a big PR boost
by being arrested so in that way it
might help his campaign for re-election
but let's not fool ourselves it would be
very hard to run a presidential campaign
from prison okay we've seen this once
before in American history
and
that that was the Socialist candidate
back in 1912 I think it was and he he
got eight percent but eight percent is
not going to win you a Race So
it
1912 or 1920 it might have been 1920.
I'll look it up afterward uh regardless
people don't win elections from prison
it would make it hard for Trump to raise
money
obviously he wouldn't be out on the
campaign trail and I agree with vivek's
point this is a turning point we need a
unified front I see why other candidates
especially Ron DeSantis who Trump has
just been pummeling recently and he's
been filing uh complaints ethics
complaints against DeSantis so I get why
DeSantis wouldn't want to do it but I
think even just optically even from the
standpoint of self-interest all of the
other candidates should come out and
condemn this right now because if a
candidate is seen as benefiting
from the blobs unjust persecution of
trump
it is not going to make any primary
voter more likely to vote for that
candidate
I just it just looks
so bad it it makes the other candidates
look like they are in cahoots with the
Deep State and the blob and the Crooked
Libs who are arresting Trump and so just
even from the standpoint of pure
self-interest I think it would behoove
the other candidates in the race
anyone who's considering running not
Nikki Haley is obviously in the race
already Tim Scott looks like he wants to
run uh Rhonda Santos obviously looks
like he wants to run like Pompeo looks
like he wants to run there are a lot of
other people I think it would behoove
them
get out ahead of this if you wait until
Trump actually is indicted it will be
too late and people will remember that
it is too late okay
not a great time for a country great
great opportunity to pray for our
country and one great way to organize
your prayer life would be hallow right
now go to hallow.com Knowles during this
season of Lent we are called to abstain
from luxuries and instead more deeply
embrace our faith co-workers around the
office have mentioned giving up coffee
booze social media but how about using
this time to start building a habit of
prayer and meditation join me and
thousands of others on hallow the number
one Christian Prayer app in the United
States aloe is helping all of us to
maintain a daily prayer routine and it
can help you too download the app for
free at hallow.com
you can set prayer reminders and track
your progress along the way not sure
where to start we'll check out my
favorite podcast father Mike schmitz's
Bible in a year available on the Hello
app for brief daily readings and
Reflections or pray alongside Mark
Wahlberg Jim Caviezel and even some
world-class athletes with hallow you can
customize a personal prayer plan that
works for you listen where wherever you
are with downloadable offline sessions
download Halo halo.com Knowles and get
an exclusive three months free which
will carry you through lent and Easter
that is three months absolutely free at
hallow.com Knowles
my favorite comment on Friday is from up
all night reviews 869 who says every
time I drive past a car lot and see one
of those inflatable air dancers I hear
Michael crying out
January 6th I haven't thought of that
before but you're right that is that is
and it's not just me crying out January
6th it is me channeling all of the libs
who have told us now for years
that their Chief priority
is the preservation
of our sacred Democratic Norms our
principles the the importance it doesn't
matter who wins the elections which is
the importance of our sacred temples of
democracy oh we can arrest Trump yeah
throw them in the Paddy Wagon send them
to gitmo let's do it baby on what some I
don't know who cares you're gonna die to
ham sandwich find something you show me
the criminal I'll find you a crime throw
that guy in jail
so that we can
more easily preserve our sacred
democracy yeah okay I'm not really
buying that so anyway what is Trump
doing right now before he gets arrested
Trump is calling
for among other things
the immediate end to the war in Ukraine
here's his argument we have never been
closer to World War III than we are
today under Joe Biden
conflict so there's one exception to
what Trump is saying he says we've never
been closer to World War III than we are
today the exception to that would
probably be the Cuban Missile Crisis
where you had a U.S blockade you had
Soviet weapons into Cuba potentially you
could kick off a nuclear war
that might be the exception
but that exception which Trump is not
acknowledging here I think actually
sheds light on the rest of Trump's
proposition on how to de-escalate in
Ukraine between nuclear-armed Powers
would mean death and destruction on a
scale unmatched in human history it
would be nuclear Armageddon
nothing is more important than avoiding
that nightmare we will avoid it but we
need new leadership every day this proxy
battle in Ukraine continues we risk
global war we must be absolutely clear
that our objective is to immediately
have a total secession of hostilities
all shooting has to stop this is the
this is a redefinition of the goal in
Ukraine
Joe Biden doesn't seem to have a goal so
I guess rather than a redefinition you
could say it's a definition Trump is
saying the United States interest in
Ukraine is to stop the war
the the Biden Administration and the
blob inasmuch as they have an objective
in Ukraine it is to keep it going
to not give Russia an inch to drag this
out until
Ukraine is in the European Union until
Ukraine is in NATO perhaps until
the administration's goals only seem to
escalate the war Trump is saying my
objective here
is to stop the war this is the central
issue we need peace without delay in
addition there must also be a complete
commitment to dismantling the entire
globalist neocon establishment that is
perpetually dragging us into endless
Wars pretending to fight for freedom and
democracy abroad while they turn us into
a third world country and a third world
dictatorship right here at home
here we go real key here
Trump is saying this this neocon
establishment the war machine the
military industrial complex whatever you
want to call it they are constantly
pushing for more and more war in their
defense
I'll take that aside for a second
the argument for that more and more war
is that the United States is the global
hegemon we do run a global Empire and to
paraphrase Pericles maybe it wasn't wise
to amass that Global Empire but it would
be more dangerous to Let It Go than it
would be to maintain it so we really are
the World Police we get a lot of
benefits from being the largest Empire
and most powerful Empire on Earth and so
we've got to maintain that Empire okay
fair enough argument
even somewhat persuasive but then Trump
points out the flaw in that argument he
says the problem with that is we say
we're spreading democracy overseas we
say we're defending freedom and
democracy but what's happening all the
while we're doing that we're eroding
freedom and democracy at home and of
course that is the case
we've greatly undermined democracy
I mean you see this on the most
important social questions of the day
you saw this on the issue of abortion at
least until last year but from rovie
wait until last year
some handful of robed lawyers on the
Supreme Court took the question of
abortion away from the people took that
out of democracy the definition of
marriage when the definition of marriage
had come up on ballots even in Liberal
California it had been shot down the
suggestion that we ought to radically
redefine marriage to take away sexual
difference so what happened a robed
romantic poet on the Supreme Court by
the name of Anthony Kennedy decided to
wax philosophic and poetic and radically
redefine marriage from the bench that
whatever you think about gay marriage
quote unquote that obviously is a
diminishment of democracy
on and on and on we we're we're seeing
less and less Democratic control even
over our our Public Square
in a self-governing republic speech is
politics politics is speech so you think
the people ought to have some say over
who gets to say what and where but
that's not the case because the blob has
outsourced the censorship and policing
of speech to a handful of billionaire
oligarchs in Silicon Valley
they're not accountable to the Democracy
in any way if if you suggest hey maybe
the vaccines aren't as great as people
told us hey maybe covid's not as
dangerous as people told us hey maybe
there were some Shenanigans in the 2020
election you could be nuked from outer
space you wouldn't have any any ability
to to appeal that in the Public Square
because Google Facebook and Twitter
control ninety percent of the flow of
information around our Republic so
you're seeing democracy ebb at home
you're seeing Freedom ebb at home we're
not even allowed to decide who gets to
come into the country anymore because we
don't have borders for any practical
purposes meanwhile we say we're
spreading democracy and freedom and
nation building abroad
and Trump is saying the more we focus on
that the more we insist upon that as an
imperial objective the less say we're
allowed we can give people and we can
afford to give people in our own country
and so so at the same time paradoxically
democracy and freedom diminish at home
and Trump says we got to end that we got
to end that so that we can build up our
nation here at home and it's a strong
case
he says we're closer than we've been to
World War III the one exception shows
you Trump's thinking here because what
the neocons and the War Hawks and the uh
Empire Builders are arguing is that if
we look weak right now
that's going to invite more aggression
from Putin that's going to invite more
aggression from Xi Jinping that's going
to invite more aggression the moment we
pulled out of Afghanistan in that
disastrous way it invited Putin invited
she I don't deny that
but that doesn't mean that the only
option is world war three think about
what happened in the Cuban Missile
Crisis
the the official storyline is Kennedy
stood firm and he stared down the
Soviets and then they pulled their
missiles out of Cuba that was only half
the story the other half of the story is
Kennedy agreed to pull his missiles out
of Turkey
which was one of the provocations that
led to the Cuban Missile Crisis in the
first place
so the U.S was allowed to say a face was
allowed to look strong but we did make
certain concessions and the same is
going to have to happen in Ukraine if
you want to bring that conflict to a
close without escalating to the point of
potentially World War III with a nuclear
reformer superpower
that's what's going to have to happen
whose foreign policy has been more
realistic whose foreign policy has been
more successful
in my lifetime the most successful
foreign policy by far has been Trump
George H.W bush can make a play for it a
little bit
but when you look at the years after and
and what happened in Iraq and elsewhere
in the Middle East I'm not I think Trump
Takes the Cake
why because Trump is unpredictable
so you don't know one day he's talking
like the dubbiest dove he never wants to
use the military ever the next day he's
dropping the mother of all bombs the one
day he's saying I'm not going to start
wars I'm going to bring peace to the
Middle East the next day he's killing
Iran's top General completely
unpredictable and unpredictability is
really really important here because if
you're Vladimir Putin if you're Xi
Jinping you will Putin obviously
wouldn't have invaded Ukraine under
Trump he didn't Trump is the only
President on whose watch Vladimir Putin
has not invaded a sovereign country in
over 20 years
at George W bush Putin invades Georgia
Obama Putin invades Crimea Trump Putin
just kind of chills Biden
Putin invades further into Ukraine
why because
reportedly Trump said hey Putin if you
invade Ukraine I'll I'll hit Moscow and
if you're Putin you're thinking this is
almost certainly a bluff
but there's like a five percent chance
that it's not a bluff because Trump is
crazy and he calls nuclear dictators in
North Korea short and fat and when they
threaten nuclear war Trump says my
button's bigger and my button works and
this madman might actually do it you
just don't know you don't know 95 chance
it's fine five percent chance you can't
take that risk you can't take that risk
it's a foreign policy alternative we I
we haven't seen this from basically
anyone else in our whole
lifetime
there's a lot of wisdom in it as far as
I'm concerned speaking of
conflicts at home that we're neglecting
while we engage in Empire
Leila Jane is an 18 year old
d-transitioner she's a girl
who was pushed into transition all these
horrible mutilations and chemical
injections when she was a little kid now
she's 18.
and she says she greatly regrets it and
she's suing her doctors here's her story
I really want to say that I think you
can hear it right away
the people who tell you there are no
long-term consequences it's all totally
reversible if a child starts to
transition
and then stops transitioning it's no big
deal this girl's voice is quite deep and
it's going to be deep for the rest of
her life and there's nothing to change
about that this girl has aspects now in
her body which are
quite masculine because she was pushed
into this as a kid and there's no
reversal for that and someone has to be
held accountable as she says
I should have been allowed to change my
sex before I could legally consent to
have sex overall I don't think I'm
better off for the experience and I
think transition just completely added
fuel to the fire that was my
pre-existing conditions
her pre-existing conditions she's
talking about psychological conditions
conditions that I am not even allowed to
mention on certain big Tech platforms I
am not even allowed to suggest that
transgender identity
has significant let's say overlap with
other
conditions let's say am I allowed to say
that can I say that one sensors
Layla's saying that she's saying this
happened to me and I wasn't treated for
other
conditions I had I was treated as though
I were really a boy and now I deeply
regret it they did this to me before I
was even legally allowed to consent to
sex her lawyer is our friend Harmony
Dylan here's what harmeet says
she was not given the mental health
treatment necessary and it was not
disclosed to her family or to her that
that for example a teenage transitioners
desist from transition at a 80 to 90
percent rate that the majority of people
who go through this regret it later on
that it wasn't a solution for her mental
health problems that many girls in fact
most girls probably struggle with
puberty and so it is our position
legally as a matter of law that informed
consent was missing here because it is
it impossible for a child to give
informed consent and it is impossible
for parents who are not fully informed
and with a child that was not properly
treated to also give that consent and
Laura an important Point here is that
you know you've had me on with our
client Chloe Cole as well and Kaiser
doctors use the line on her and her
parents would you rather have a live son
or a dead daughter the exact same line
was used in this case so it appears to
be a script that's certain Kaiser
doctors and psychiatrists are using on
on these victims
this kind of
Butchery
is totally irresponsible at the levels
of the parents yes at the levels of the
school yes
but at the level of the doctors okay the
doctors need someone needs to be held
responsible and what you're going to
hear from the squishes as well the
doctors were just doing their jobs well
we shouldn't look people should be free
to choose whatever they want well
Layla's point is I can't be free to
choose whatever I want when I'm 13 I'm
30 I'm below the age of consent
okay and for for these these people
whose job it is first to do no harm to
be making these life-altering decisions
for me before I can consent
is deeply deeply wrong
you know how it's wrong you know how we
know it's wrong because the federal
government which now pretends that
transitioning at a very young age is
wonderful and great and we support
transiting the kids even the Biden
official who is in charge of that
Richard Levine who now calls himself
Rachel admitted in a clip that's now
cropped up
that he is grateful that he did not
transition until he was an adult I have
no regrets because if I transition
whether I was young and I wouldn't have
like and so every experience led me to
here and
um and so how could I regret that
he makes a great Point had he
transitioned that is to say been
castrated when he was a little kid he
wouldn't have been able to have children
and for so many of these d transitioners
one of the most painful aspects of the
regret is that they've been sterilized
that they've been castrated that they
won't be able to have kids I look at my
little kids this is the this is the
greatest joy that I can imagine in this
world at least
and you don't think about that when
you're 13 when you're 14 when you're
going through puberty when you're going
through an awkward phase when you've got
some anxiety about your body when your
friends are all wrapped up in this
bizarre fad of gender ideology and
you're sucked into it you don't think
about those things but but
even just a few years later even at 18
you can begin to think of that and say
oh my goodness what have I done and the
children should not be held responsible
for what's been done the parents should
the schools should the government should
and the doctors should and if we don't
hold them responsible if we don't
insist upon consequences for bad
behavior
you're going to get more of that bad
behavior and that's unjust certainly to
the victims it's unjust even to the
perpetrators we'll get into why that's
the case in just a second first though
it's easy enough to look around the
world
and even around our own circumstances
and get a little bit discouraged that
discouragement can often seem
insurmountable but did you know
the opposite is true with a little
encouragement your whole world view can
change that is what Jordan Peterson
talks about in his new five-part series
vision and Destiny and daily wire plus
here's a clip
you're not all you could be
and there's pain in that and there's the
necessity for a certain amount of
judgment about that and even a certain
amount of exclusion because what you are
that is insufficient in some sense
should be not be allowed to propagate
further but if it's conjoined with
encouragements like yeah you're in a
rough situation there kiddo but you know
here's some things about you that are
virtuous and good and they're pretty
powerful actually and if you just
made those more manifest you could
dispense with the law to this immaturity
and misery and you could expand yourself
out into life physically and
psychologically and
you could start
walking this pathway that makes things
better and the thing is that as soon as
you start walking the pathway that makes
things better then things immediately
become better because your whole
orientation changes and you know if
you're in a bad place but you're
escaping that's pretty positive
even if it's a bad place and you might
think well it's still bad but it's
better it's like well that's a lot
that's a lot better than a bad place
that's getting worse that's for sure
because that's hell hell is a bad place
that's getting worse
the fifth and final episode of vision
and Destiny is out now exclusively for
daily wire Plus members join at
dailywire.com subscribe to watch vision
and Destiny
we've got to arrest some criminal Libs
in response to the libs potentially
arresting Donald Trump
we've got to sue the doctors who
transition the meaning mutilate and
castrate the poor little kids who they
are leading into a gender ideology we
have to do that
as a mercy not only to the victims of
these predations but also to the
perpetrators and people they don't think
about that very often but the
enforcement of consequences is a mercy
even to the criminals you saw this there
was a video that went completely viral
on Friday and it's of a criminal busting
and walking into a Metro PCS store
and he's got a gun
he throws a bag down on the counter to
the clerk
basically the clerk said the the
criminal saying fill up this bag with
the money I'm going to walk around here
brandishing my gun threatening your life
and just fill it up totally casual and
what happens the clerk is armed
the store had been robbed multiple times
but the clerk is armed and so he pulls
out his weapon he fires he empties this
Magazine on this Criminal
criminal dies
this video has been described on social
media as the F around and find out video
it's very sad we're blurring the image
of the criminal because I don't want to
be airing snuff films on my show
but this is a case in which
the the clerk was absolutely 100 what
right somebody walks in and threatens
you with a gun that person has
surrendered their expectation that they
get to live okay that is that is a fight
or flight kind of scenario and that guy
who knows maybe that guy's got a wife
maybe that guy's got kids maybe that guy
just once has a natural desire to
protect his own life and he pulls that
out and he says I cannot allow you to
threaten my life boom boom boom boom
boom criminals dead for what for what
for the prospect of making whatever
pittance was in the cash register at
MetroPCS and stealing some cell phones
for what this guy threw away his life
why was the guy impelled to rob the
store
because of his bad upbringing because he
violated the moral order because he made
a bad choice sure also because
other people had gotten away with it
that's the most preventable part of the
whole story
and it's the part for which the libs
bear a lot of responsibility and it's
the part for which The Bleeding Hearts
the part for which the criminal justice
reformers bear a lot of responsibility
if they would keep their traps shut and
allow law enforcement to do its job and
allow criminals to face consequences
that guy
would very possibly be alive today
because he wouldn't have dared to walk
into that shop brandishing a gun
threatening a clerk if he thought he
were going to face consequences for that
it is I remember at a at a very very
small scale I remember I was giving a
speech at the University of Missouri
Kansas City some years ago
this was before the transgender
topic became the biggest Topic in the
whole country I was giving a speech
called men are not women and other
uncomfortable truths
and
these Maniacs at the speech these
leftist activists were screaming like
banshees like hyenas you couldn't hear a
word they were
defying and jumping up and down and
really behaving like animals and finally
though they decided okay we're gonna
leave
because I just kept giving my speech
one person I guess they had planned this
out
one person gets to the side a little bit
behind the podium
and opens up a fire door and I guess
there had been another activist on the
other side of the door waiting to come
in and attack me and he wasn't attacking
me with a gun well it was a type of a
gun it was a squirt gun filled with some
kind of dubious fluids we've never
figured out exactly what was in this
work on I was designed though to seem
like a chemical of some sort and the guy
comes in
he sprays me with this workout and I
just feel a little bit of this squirt
gun and by the time I squared up on him
so we're talking about seconds by the
time I turn and square up on this guy he
is already down on the ground because
there was a cop behind him
and the cop eventually because he was
fighting the cop cop eventually tases
him and I looked down at this guy's face
and I'm just watching this happen and
the look on the guy's face it was not
one of anger it was a little bit of pain
for sure but the the the look that is
seared into my memory is one of shock
surprise
he thought he was going to get away with
it
and he was he couldn't believe that
there would be consequences for his
actions and I I don't want to sound like
a big lib squish or anything like a
bleeding heart here but I have some
sympathy for him because he had good
reason to think he would get away with
it because the school took the side of
the crazy leftist activists all the time
because at events all around the country
in recent years we've seen at Yale law
school at heart at Stanford law school
the top two law schools in the country
these students behaving exactly the same
crazy
unreasonable way and they get away with
it and the administration takes their
side
so this kid thought he would get away
with it
happened to be the case that in our
events we don't let people get away with
it and so the guy ended up in jail
it's kind of the way markets work
markets work on
reliability stability
markets want to be able to predict
what's going to happen more than even
they want a tax cut they want a tax hike
they want this regulation they want the
they just want predictability okay and
we have a country
that is increasingly not predictable and
it's not predictable because we used to
be a country of law
and we are increasingly a country of men
we used to be a country that was ruled
by the Constitution
by law law Lady Justice blindly
uh meeting out Justice
now we are increasingly a country of the
Caprices of men
where if you're a liberal you can commit
all sorts of crimes all sorts of
corruption take money hand over fist
from Ukraine from communist China you
you can you can commit and admit to
countless crimes on your computer on
video in your own words
implicating your father was the
president of the United States you'll
get away with it
but if the regime doesn't like you
they'll find some bogus reason from
seven years ago to throw you into an
orange jumpsuit
and in that kind of society
in a society where people think there
are not going to be consequences for
their actions
the actions of the people in power and
the reactions of the people who are out
of power are increasingly going to spin
out of control that's just how it works
okay today's music Monday the rest of
the show continues now you don't want to
miss it become a member use code Knowles
kwels at checkout for two months free on
all annual plans we will see you over at
the membrane segment room
[Music]
oh